[Music]
I wish people would be more
experimentive with their music I think
that's like the thing that like I really
don't like Kanye West in his music or
anything but I appreciate the amount of
like experimentation he does with his
music and stuff that I wish that people
would like take greater risks in their
career and especially like changes of
like something of like trying to do
something of genuine interest or like
trying to do something of genuine growth
I think is interesting so see doesn't
that [ __ ] a lot of artists especially on
their sophomore album when they try to
do something I don't think that you I
don't think you have to evolve that
quickly but I think if you're somebody
like Kanye or if you're somebody like if
you have like a reputable career I think
that like after a while you need to do
something that's like yeah not even
necessarily a pivotal change but you
should like challenge yourself
constantly yeah so it's like I don't
think that like buyer sophomore release
you don't have to like challenge that
voice that you have because you're still
like figuring out out what that is but
like once you have a fully realized
voice you should do something that like
challenges yourself yeah definitely and
that's like with anything that's like
why like so many people will become like
like older stuff becomes shitty or stuff
because they have nothing new to say
which is fine because that's just like
human nature and like there's a thing
that says like uh
like right now we're tailored towards
the end of our creative like in terms of
like I forgot what the [ __ ] it's called
but like your brain right now and like
we're at like the end of that of like
where you are starting to like perceive
the world in a way where you have
interesting things to say that does come
to an end there's like a scientific
thing about that and then after a while
your brain goes into a crystallized
state where you become like a better
teacher because like of your experiences
and stuff so like the youth will always
have something more interesting and like
look at the world in like a unique way
and then like when you're older that's
why like there's no [ __ ] like 17 year
old philosophers and if there are it's
[ __ ] and who I were all kind of
locked into being like racist
[Laughter]
well this is the most racist podcast oh
yeah okay all right yeah yeah he's
like an old bit we used to print we used
to [ __ ] with people when they listened
to the show early on roughly we'd be
like you've tuned in to the most racist
podcast in the world and we're just
hoping people be in a stoplight like
let's just scramble that's funny oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] off man don't do that right now
yeah do you guys feel like the show is
in a place where uh you guys do you feel
like you I mean it seems like you guys
do quite a bit to like do new
and like they're like a challenge
yourself to do new things I feel like
you have to do that in any sort of
creative
what you do but do you feel like you're
Proactive or do you like because the
thing is that people know that but
people go about it in a very safe way so
like I think that some people can go on
lines of like this is new or whatever
but like it's a very safe bet not that
you have to take risky bets but I think
sometimes people don't proactively
actually challenge themselves in ways
that like they know they should I think
we're pretty good about naturally
challenging ourselves yeah I think so
I'm just curious if like your own
perception of it you know because I
think so I think you guys do a lot of
cool [ __ ] like I said I already told you
I thought the struggle was like so
[ __ ] funny and so good [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's really really good thanks dude I
think that we have that in common about
our personality where we in the moment
we never feel like we're doing enough
but then if you look back yeah it's like
oh actually what we did what we did was
pretty like creative and challenging
ourselves yeah like we definitely did
bite off a little bit more than we could
chew but in the moment it's like oh look
at Mr Beast look at all these guys that
are doing so much more than us yeah so
it like pushes us to like keep going
let's put a big thing I want to talk to
you about this isn't a dig are you about
any means is a legitimate question oh
geez what I said
no I'm about to say like if you use your
neck like you do something
a lot like new channels all kinds of
stuff to the extent where it's a lot in
perspective to what like a normal
YouTuber person does do you feel like
you're ever able to give your like
attention to something to like have the
best kind of quality or do you feel like
you're at a race to always do something
new yeah I I feel like it's it's kind of
a a hindrance sometimes to really to
yeah because I think like people that
actually really focus on one or two
things and put everything like I mean I
don't know
it's how I've always done things is by
like spreading myself a little bit too
thin because then that's how I find the
things that work for me but um I do
definitely sometimes feel like oh man
like once I find that thing I should
probably pour myself into it but I kind
of stay spread a little bit thin but I
don't know it's worked so far sometimes
with like personal work
I think I get very like complacent and I
feel scared because I'm like this is too
comfortable or this is something where
I'm like this isn't working or something
so I feel like I have to like left turn
or whatever really quickly which I think
everybody feels that way I'm just
curious yeah well I've taken a lot of
left turns
I think I've taken too many
in the last two years yeah dude it's so
funny when I look back at some of my
personal projects I'm like oh that was
just like pure Mania right there like
just woke up unmedicated as [ __ ] like I
need to do this and then everyone being
like all right I can't I think you both
have been doing some very interesting
things lately like they insanely chill I
I tuned in for your buddy Jimmy was oh
yeah Jimmy I thought that was a good one
but I think there's like that whole set
and stuff that's really fun and also
like the vibe we've been doing on your
Channel with like uh I love all the
living room videos thanks like just
making it feel like very
like it's just like in the moment kind
of thing yeah I think that's fun you it
feels like you guys are like more
artists in the sense where it's like
people are gonna [ __ ] with your cartoons
no matter what or your music videos or
like the stuff that you like are more
Visionary about sure where I'm always
just scared like as a as a personality
it's like you do have like three to five
years where it's like that's your time
if you don't take full advantage of it
yeah people will just like forget about
you which happens like the people that
really make it like 10 years are like
Markiplier and PewDiePie and that's it
you know what I'm saying yeah and and us
to a certain degree because we also say
you you've gone past that to a point or
do you feel like a security at all no I
don't feel it at all I feel like that's
probably with everybody I feel like
maybe I bet you even Markiplier and
stuff feels the same way about being
yeah
having even though it's a like to us
it's irrational but somebody who's
living in those things the goal post no
matter who you are always changes yeah I
think yeah and I think even your success
is like mean less over time yep you
wonder if you experience such an
abundance of success things that you do
that people are like you're doing
amazing I mean very they hold little
substance to you I think it's so funny
that that Rift between like traditional
entertainment and
the internet is like it's very much
alive in comedy clubs because there have
been a plethora of like what they call
internet people who come lock down for a
weekend and everyone at the club is just
like gritting their teeth like they're
just like seething like either
in what way like some some people like
shut it down and they'll get on this get
on stage and they're doing like some
[ __ ] up there they'll come up there
and they're kind of like singing and
doing weird like variety acts and they
just do a q a and it's like a 35 minute
show then they just leave what the
club's experience is people kind of just
cashing in basically and you know just
rinsing Their audience for money so it's
actually very interesting because I'll
come into a lot of these clubs and some
of the staff you know I don't blame them
like I don't hold it against them but
they're very like
[ __ ] here we go like another one of
these and they're like they're not very
nice they're pretty rude and some staff
like genuinely kind of treats me like
[ __ ] from the moment I get in and I'm
just sort of I'm like okay like I know
where it's coming from just comes with
the territory almost yeah and so then
I'll get up on stage and then by the end
of the weekend it's like then I've won
them over and they're kind of like hey
man like you know they all say the same
thing like oh wow like you're actually a
stand-up like that's the phrasing they
use the amount of date you do is like
insane yeah I mean you know I I think
it's like I know I know that I I ripped
on that a bit in the main one but like
it's like at a point it's like when when
do you think you're gonna like when when
will it actually stop
so this is like your your agents might
say something like hey there's this
region that does this or whatever but
when are you gonna be like I've done my
[ __ ] fair share I want to work on
some new [ __ ] or something like that
because I know you're also the set
you're doing now from whenever the
[ __ ] tour started however millenniums
ago your set has changed like it's not
the same set forever no no yeah so now
I'm at the point where I actually like
taking long breaks between the shows and
then going back and then trying to
remember what I wrote Because I'll say
it much differently and I find that I
say it in a more truncated way and it
like so it's like this like natural like
trimming of the fat so I almost feel a
stand-up there's like this period you
have to go through where at least for me
where it's like it goes from because
when I first started doing the shows
like an hour and 10 minutes and now I
get it down to like about 48 minutes
it's just way tighter it's yeah it's
just like all the important pieces are
in there so you're gonna record your set
though you think yeah and I think dude
[ __ ] stand up on YouTube right now is
killing is so good every single person
post is special I think it's I think I
really start noticing it with I think it
was Shane Gillis I think his was it the
first one where I was like oh my God and
then like it was doing very well yeah
and then Stavros made one his and then
Andrew Schultz or like all everybody's
doing it and then Ari shafir even just
came out even uh Norman's uh special did
really well and Mark who Mark Norman and
so he did make yeah Joe Joe list pulling
out it's just funny that it's like
people used to be like oh you're putting
it on YouTube because of [ __ ] Gringo
poppy yeah and everybody hated that
they're like oh God he had to put it on
YouTube but it's like such a way more
convenient place yeah it's like you're
gonna get your stuff out you're gonna be
like you will grow your fan base
exponentially from just putting out on
YouTube yeah I hope I don't put it out
too late but I don't well I just think
it's going to become a norm I think it's
literally that is the New Frontier first
because to me when I see like people
like a new Netflix special it's just
like tired like nobody wants to watch a
Netflix I just feel like every new
Netflix comedy special comes out you
know it's going to be kind of like over
produce watered down yep they all feel
like that and the ones I've watched on
Netflix it actually feels like comedy
that I don't know stand-up specials that
you used to watch where it's like oh
they're trying to push them I mean
there's a little bit what you said
YouTube sorry yeah yeah YouTube well so
it's much more intimate yeah intimate
it's like smaller sometimes it's like
smaller venues and it feels like it's
less rehearsed the era of like really
big theater recording thing to show like
look who I am kind of thing I think
that's done
so I think having a more like intimate
set where people can like feel like
they're more connected with a person is
definitely better but like especially
for stand-up it just makes sense you
don't need to have like somebody come
out during your tour and do this huge
elaborate [ __ ] filming thing and have
like a Comedy Central because back in
the day it was like Comedy Central I got
my I got my first Comedy Central set or
whatever yeah and then from there was
like HBO and or like you know then you
would evolve to HBO or whatever but yeah